en el vídeo introductorio de la ecuación
de hardy pinter vimos algunas
condiciones importantes que en este
vídeo me gustaría profundizar un poco
más y como un repaso de la ecuación de
hardy para ver supongamos que si tenemos
una población con el gen para digamos
para el color de los ojos supongamos que
ese gen puede existir en dos versiones
uno es el alelo que produce azul y el
otro alelo produce café que es la
frecuencia del alelo azul y q es la
frecuencia del alelo café y solamente
hay dos versiones y si sumamos la
frecuencia de p
el azul más la frecuencia del café eso
nos da el cien por ciento es decir 1 y
si elevamos ambos lados de la ecuación
al cuadrado obtenemos esta expresión y
hablamos de que esta es la probabilidad
o mejor dicho la frecuencia de ser homo
cigoto azul
esta es la probabilidad de tener 2 sale
los cafés y finalmente esta es la
probabilidad de
heterocigotos y porque bueno porque
puede ser que a un alelo azul sea de tu
mama y el café de tu papá o el azul de
tu papa y el café de tu mamá así que hay
dos formas de lograr esa combinación pq
ahora aquí la idea principal es que
hardy peimbert supone una frecuencia de
alelo o mejor dicho una frecuencia
alélica estable porque todas estas
condiciones buscan las formas diferentes
en las que no se tenga una frecuencia de
alelo estable entonces con hardy
peimbert vamos a suponer que la
frecuencia alélica la frecuencia alélica
es estable
ahora sé que muchas veces ustedes tratan
de memorizar todo esto pero la idea más
importante es pensar si de alguna forma
algo podría causar que la frecuencia
alélica sea inestable y bueno otra forma
de decir que hay una frecuencia alélica
estable es que no hay evolución no hay
evolución recuerden que la evolución es
un cambio en los rasgos hereditarios de
una población y eso incluye un cambio en
la frecuencia alélica y si pensamos en
los dos factores que hacen que una
población evolucione podemos pensar en
la selección natural entonces vamos a
suponer que no existe selección bueno en
realidad hay más de dos factores podemos
pensar en ingeniería genética y todo eso
pero vamos a suponer que principalmente
no hay selección natural y también
podemos suponer que no hay deriva génica
recordemos que la selección natural toma
en cuenta ciertos rasgos que hacen que
un organismo sea más apto para el medio
ambiente por lo que esos rasgos pasarán
a las siguientes generaciones mientras
que la deriva génica es un cambio
aleatorio de la frecuencia alélica y
puede ser debido a poblaciones pequeñas
o debido a que los miembros de una
población migran a otro lado o si ocurre
el efecto de cuello de botella es decir
si ocurre un desastre natural y la
población que sobrevive es pequeña
entonces ese es el panorama general pero
sabiendo todo esto me gustaría que
profundizaremos más en las suposiciones
que verán en su clase de biología para
que se sientan cómodos con ellas y se
darán cuenta de que estamos hablando de
lo mismo vamos a ver primero tenemos que
no hay selección y eso es consistente
porque no hay evolución también hablamos
de que no hay mutación neta que también
es consistente si no hay evolución
porque recuerden que no queremos cambiar
la frecuencia
al el ica y si existiera mutación eta
tal vez alguna de las versiones del gen
azul puede tener una mutación y tal vez
ahora sea una versión diferente o tal
vez ya ni siquiera es un gen azul así
que la frecuencia alélica podría cambiar
y la razón por la que nos preocupamos
por una población grande es
principalmente por la deriva génica
porque si tenemos una población muy
pequeña es más probable que al azar las
frecuencias alélicas pueden cambiar
apreciablemente ahora muchas veces
también verán otras condiciones como el
apareamiento al azar en el que si un
organismo tiene una versión del gen azul
o café eso no lo hace más o menos
deseable para un miembro del sexo
opuesto y si lo pensamos un poco tal vez
me diga oye y eso no es una forma de
selección natural si de cierta forma lo
es pero eso muchas veces se puede evadir
de otra forma y también puede ser cuando
no hay migración es decir si una
población no crece o disminuye por la
presencia de otro
organismos que llegan o se van si no hay
una mezcla de dos poblaciones y
nuevamente todo esto es porque nos
interesa mantener las frecuencias
alélicas estables ahora si profundizamos
aún más bueno yo solamente he mencionado
los factores más importantes que nos
llevan a una frecuencia alélica estable
no evolución no selección no deriva
génica pero muchas veces suponemos que
estamos trabajando con organismos
diploides es decir que obtenemos un
conjunto de cromosomas de nuestra madre
y otro de nuestro padre así que una
versión del alelo es de tu mamá y una
versión del alelo es de tu papá y tal
vez me digan oye entonces qué tipo
existe además de diplo y de bueno
también existen poblaciones triploides
sobre todo en las plantas o puede
ocurrir que obtenemos dos conjuntos de
cromosomas de nuestra madre y dos
conjuntos de cromosomas de nuestro padre
entonces estamos suponiendo reproducción
sexual
sexual no estamos hablando de clonación
en donde solamente seríamos una copia de
otro organismo generación tras
generación y suponemos que si tenemos
ojos de color azul o café o si tenemos
las dos versiones eso no tiene nada que
ver con el sexo que seamos entonces la
frecuencia alélica
la frecuencia alélica
es igual
en todos los sexos
y estamos suponiendo reproducción sexual
así que únicamente existen dos sexos y
bueno si dejamos volar a nuestra
imaginación podemos pensar en un montón
de otras restricciones que podríamos
incluir aquí con las que ya no aplica la
ecuación de hardy vainberg en donde se
necesitan dos alelos pero de momento
sabemos que aplica en la reproducción
sexual organismos diploides que obtienen
los alelos de la madre y del padre y
estas son las condiciones que nos ayudan
a asegurar una frecuencia alélica
estable ahora probablemente me diga ok
diploide reproducción sexual ok pero no
hay siempre una oportunidad para la
deriva génica en la historia del mundo
así fue como ocurrió esta evolución y la
respuesta es sí por eso es que en
realidad son muy pocas las poblaciones
en las que podemos aplicar puramente la
ecuación dejar divine ver pero como
muchas otras cosas en las ciencias
aplicadas es una muy buena aproximación
para muchas poblaciones
por eso es muy útil